women have a certain level of
requirements to sleep with a man because
some people say oh women have sex and
because it takes a lot more for women to
have sex but I've literally seen girls
that will sleep with men and feel no
type yeah but they don't they don't
start like that too they do they don't
know typically they're not typically
they don't typically they don't
typically start they become that but
when they're 15 16 17 18 whenever they
lose their virginity they're not they
don't they're not born a Savage they're
made because and that's and that's why
men don't want girls that are ran
through because you you can't connect as
much the more people you slept with